another historic moment
this is perhaps outside but perhaps
within your uh
space of frameworks that you think about
that just happened
i guess a couple weeks ago is um i don't
know if you're paying attention at all
it's the
the game stop and wall street bets
so it's really fascinating there's kind
of a theme to this conversation
today because it's like you know that
works
it's cool how there's a large number of
people in a distributed way
almost having a kind of fun we're able
to take on
the powerful elites uh elite hedge funds
centralized powers and overpower them
uh do you have thoughts i mean saga
i don't know enough about finance but it
was like the elon
you know robin hood guy when they talk
yeah what do you think about that
well the revenue guy didn't know how the
finance system worked that was clear
right he was treating like the the
people who settled the transactions as a
black box
and suddenly somebody called him up and
said hey black box calling you your
transaction volume means you need to put
out three billion dollars right now and
he's like i don't have three billion
dollars
like i don't even make any money on
these trades why do i owe three billion
dollars while you're sponsoring a trade
so so there was a set of abstractions
that
you know i don't think either like like
now he understands it like
this happens in chip design like you buy
wafers from tsmc or samsung or intel
and you know they say it works like this
and you do your design based on that and
then chip comes back and doesn't work
and then suddenly he started having to
open the black boxes like the
transistors really work like they said
you know what's the real issue
so so the
there's a whole set of things that
created this opportunity and somebody
spotted it
now people spot these kinds of
opportunities all the times there's been
flash crashes there's been
you know there's always short squeezes
are fairly regular every ceo i know
hates the shorts because they're they're
manipulating
they're trying to manipulate their stock
in a way that they make money
and you know deprive value from both
this you know the company and the
investors
so the fact that
you know some of these stocks were so
short it's hilarious
that this hasn't happened before i don't
know why and i don't actually know why
some serious hedge funds didn't do it to
other hedge funds
and some of the hedge funds actually
made a lot of money on this yes
so my guess is we know
five percent of what really happened and
that a lot of the players don't know
what happened
and the people who probably made the
most money aren't the people that
they're talking about
yeah that's do you think there was
something uh
i mean this is the this is the cool kind
of uh
elon uh you're the same kind of
conversationalist which is like first
principles
questions of like what the hell happened
uh just very basic questions of like was
there something shady going on
uh what you know who are the parties
involved it's the basic questions
everybody wants to know about
yeah so like we're in a very hyper
competitive world
right but transactions like buying and
selling stock is a trust event
you know i trust the company
representing themselves properly you
know
i bought the stock because i think it's
going to go up i trust that the
regulations are solid
now inside of that there's all kinds of
places where
you know humans over trust and
you know this this expose let's say some
weak points in the system
i don't know if it's going to get
corrected i don't know if the
i don't know if we have close to the
real story
yeah my suspicion is we don't yeah and
listen to that guy
he was like a little wide-eyed about and
then he did this and then they did that
and i was like
yeah so i think you should know more
about that your business than that
but again there's many businesses when
like this layer is really stable
you stop paying attention to it you pay
attention to the stuff that's bugging
you
or new you don't pay attention to the
stuff that just seems to work all the
time you just
you know the sky's blue every day
california and everywhere once a while i
think
you know it rains there was like what do
we do
somebody go bring in the lawn furniture
you know like it's getting wet you don't
know it's getting wet
yeah it doesn't it was blue for like 100
days and now it's
you know so but part of the problem here
with vlad
this the ceo of robin hood is is the
scaling is that what we've been talking
about is
there's a lot of unexpected things that
happen with the scaling
and you have to be i think the scaling
forces you to then return to the
fundamentals
well it's interesting because when you
buy and sell stocks the scaling is you
know the stocks only move in a certain
range and if you buy stock you can only
lose that amount of money
on the short short market you can lose a
lot more than you can
benefit like it has a it has a weird
cost you know cost function or whatever
the right word for that is
so he was trading in a market where he
wasn't actually capitalized for the
downside
if it got outside a certain range
now whether something the various has
happened i have no idea
but at some point the
financial risk to both him and his
customers was way outside of his
financial capacity
and his understanding how the system
work was clearly
weak or or he didn't represent himself i
you know i don't know the person
when i listened to him nick yeah it
could have been the surprise question
was like
these guys called and you know it
sounded like
he was treating stuff as a black box
maybe he shouldn't have
but maybe his whole pile expert
somewhere else and it was going on i
don't i don't know
yep i mean this is uh this is one of the
qualities of
a good leader is under fire you have to
perform
and that means to think clearly and to
speak clearly
and he dropped the ball on those things
because
and understand the problem quickly learn
and understand the problem
like at this like basic level
like what the hell happened and my guess
is
you know at some level it was amateurs
trading against
you know experts slash insiders slash
people with you know special information
outsiders just as insiders yeah and the
insiders
you know my guess is the next time this
happens we'll make money on it
the insiders always win well they have
more tools and more incentive i mean
this always happens like the outsiders
are doing this for fun the insiders are
doing this 24 7.
but there's numbers in the outsiders
this is the interesting thing
there's numbers on the insiders too like
different kind of numbers different kind
of numbers but this could be a new era
because
i don't know at least i didn't expect
that uh a bunch of redditors could
you know there's uh you know millions of
people would get a guy's attack
the next one won't be a surprise but
don't you think the
the the crowd the people are planning
the next attack
we'll see but it has to be a surprise
can't be the same game
as to the end it could be there's a very
large number of games to play and they
can be
agile about it i don't know i'm not an
expert right that's a good question how
the space of games how how restricted is
it
yeah and the system is so complicated it
could be relatively unrestricted
and also like you know during the last
couple financial crashes
you know what set it off was you know
sets of derivative events where
you know the you know nasim talib's you
know thing is
they're they're they're trying to lower
volatility
in the short run but creating tail
events and
systems always evolve towards that and
then they always crash like
the s-curve is the you know star-low
ramp plateau crash it's 100
effective in the long run
you